how much of a prince charming is
is this gentleman right here in this
movie i mean it's i i can barely contain
myself it's crazy oh chris
stopped with me oh my god
you know what this does happen
hello ladies
hey looking good i saw you on the x
factory nicole oh that's cool
nicole here i am what are your other two
wishes
[Applause]
you use that use that machine
now listen i know i'm paid to chat but i
think it's fair if i just put the cards
down and we all just stare at henry for
a while
[Applause]
no russell even you must look at henry
and kind of go you know what you could i
mean
do you have any baby mamas
i could you could
can we go to break please
we're never going to break him
like this
we're never going to break
oh we still got yeah
i i assure you this is an area in which
i'm confident i am not bluffing
i i will take care of you i will make
you see multi-colored i'll make you
forget your own name
sorry
idris elba you're making me a bit
nervous
but i'm just sociologically programmed
to want chocolate on valentine's day
[Applause]
that's what's going on he's going to say
to me naomi
hey steve how's it going how you doing
the word of the week is legs let's go
back to mine and spread the word
i find that extremely
extremely vulnerable oh come on that was
dynamite
is there any advice you could give him
perhaps i mean you know these things any
advice he would well there's there i
mean he i think he's pretty smart yeah
uh borat but he's also a quick learner
yeah yeah i think you are i think you
want to learn don't you yes and so if i
depend what you want to teach me
and the other one is another male
species has got long
quills coming out of his tail
and what he does is to turn around and
then flick his friend across the face
with his crew oh that wouldn't work with
me at all
i could show you later
you do all that you go to the dance and
club with people you don't know
i mean i don't make that noise yeah
i mean i know how seriously comic book
nerds take this kind of stuff because i
am one of them really what do you think
about my breasts
a what
[Applause]
tell you what it sounds weird i don't
know hold on let me figure it out
okay
they look great yeah both of them thank
you
thank you no no i was joking and it
might be a bad joke i'm blessed
me too trevor
yes ma'am
don't call me ma'am i'm sorry i'm just i
respect you so much don't respect me
oh thank you god
[Laughter]
katie this is the man you need listen if
you're not going to hollywood maybe you
can just come hang out with me
so the third thing i got was a surfboard
i i figured i'd get all the essentials i
don't even know how to surf but it
doesn't matter oh i know how to surf i
could teach you this is a
something's happening right now your
surfing might be a little different but
i'm down to learn
it looks to me like melanie may well be
up for it because she seems to be
responding in a way yeah i think uh i
think he's why because you were you were
making flirtatious eyes when he said
that yeah it was a frightened expression
how much is she
because you you didn't want to be as i
did one of the zoologists that was what
i thought that i was going to be my
entire life i wanted to study
the um
i have to teach you also
i've learned a lot from you already
kathy do you watch the david's book yeah
i do david i'll watch out
you'll have to move out of your chair
and catharine is welcome no no she's not
it's not no don't do it trust me don't
do this
don't even say for the queen you can't
don't say for the queen for the queen
do you want to do the awkward pause i
mean it is about time no no let's not do
the awkwardness you don't want to see
the awkward pass
it's so awkward
what do you want to do then i want to
feel comfortable
yeah come over here then
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
in my life
through everyone
it must have been so challenging having
to work with henry every day it's just
so awful it's just too bad about his
face right
he's such a nice guy and then you know i
kind of feel bad because in all of the
press it's like obvious so people are
constantly asking the question and then
i'm like henry's gonna take out a
restraining order on me if i keep
talking about how cute he is and like
giggling in his presence but i challenge
anyone to stare in his eyes for five
seconds and not giggle so
yeah it is not easy i'm definitely not
up to that challenge nobody really is
the nicest guy and so humble and has so
many other wonderful qualities that you
kind of forget and then you see other
people react to him and you're like oh
yeah he's
really good looking and yeah you know
and i wonder honestly i mean it's it's
sort of a cliche
to like usually i'm saying it when
you're not around so now i'm like
females where women sometimes there is
such a thing uh as being
too ridiculously good looking as they
would say i haven't had that problem i
don't know you're pretty beautiful too
amy but do you worry at all henry about
it getting in the way of your acting and
for people in terms of people taking you
seriously for your craft instead of your
packaging
i said packaging i think she just
she just touched you i said i did i said
packaging
i had like a little my backup you know
and so no i didn't want to play them so
a lot's changed in the last five years
for you
[Applause]
what kind of person is jennifer
christopher oh
my favorite question
unless you tell her the truth
she's the worst
no when she walks into a room there's
not a person in the room that doesn't
know she's got uh she glows she does she
glows and she's got a very intoxicating
personality and and
and it's just fun to be around what
makes him the best
um
pretty much every everything i've always
i mean he's
one of my favorite people to work with
to be around
and um
yeah i love that you know i like the
gushing what do you love about playing
with her oh my god it's the same thing i
mean
i mean personally yes we're good friends
sense of humor intelligence mind view of
the world beautiful heart beautiful
spirit and a damn fine actress my god
the harmonica just really kind of just
got into my blood yeah it's good do you
play yourself and i no i just got one
though and i want to learn so maybe you
can be my teacher no no i can't maybe i
could is that the sore leg
yes the doctor told me to elevate it so
here we go
no
this is the late late show right
it is now yeah
oh there's a horse in the corner
the horse looks like he's doing
something else it's very late lately
what's going on that's jeff
where am i
who's that guy
that guy one thing i'm not gay anymore
[Applause]
yeah wow
can you find you want a piece of fruit
i would love a piece of fruit uh what do
you fancy a banana uh okay yeah
there you are it leans a bit to one side
but you'll be all right
[Applause]